la vidéo verbalisation est entrée en
vigueur à partir d'aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs secteurs de la ville de tours
le quartier colbert celui de la gare de
l'hôtel de ville et le vieux tours les
caméras de vidéosurveillance vont
désormais être mise à profit pour faire
baisser le nombre des stationnements
gênants
alors comment ça marche et qu'est ce
qu'on risque désormais on fait le point
avec notre invité du jour nicolas
galdeano bonjour bonjour vous êtes donc
le directeur de la police municipale de
tours jeu là n'ont fait le lancement de
la vidéo verbalisation c'était
aujourd'hui est-ce que d'ores et déjà
vous avez dresser des pv aujourd'hui oui
effectivement quelques pv ont été
dressés
une douzaine au total dans la journée
donc ce majoritairement des
stationnements sur des trottoirs ou des
passages piétons qu'est ce que c'est
concrètement un stationne un
stationnement gênant est ce que par
exemple je suis je me stationne sur une
sur une place réservée à la livraison
est ce que c'est un stationnement gênant
alors du point de vue du code de la
route oui c'est un stationnement gênant
nous dans le cadre de la
vidéo-verbalisation on va même viser les
stationnements très gênant c'est à dire
des stationnements sur les pistes
cyclables les passages piétons les
trottoirs en gros dés des infractions
qui gêne mais qui rendent dangereuse les
circulations pour les personnes qui ont
le 17 les passages puis voilà enfin qui
circule en fauteuil roulant peut-être
c'est ça fait pourquoi est-ce que
jusqu'à présent les agents
verbalisateurs que l'on voit très
clairement sur le terrain qui sont là
pourquoi est ce que ne verbaliser pas
cessé stationnement gênant alors si si
c'était cet effet et par les agents de
la police municipale et par les agents
du stationnement
donc c'est un renfort en fait de leur
leur travail de terrain
c'est pas un remplacement c'est vraiment
un renfort
alors comment ça va marcher avec ses
caméras de vidéosurveillance expliqué
alors concrètement l'agent lorsqu'il
fait son travail de
deux opérateurs de vidéoprotection il
constate généralement des anomalies sur
le terrain ça c'est son travail de base
c'est la sécurisation des biens et des
personnes est ensuite vient cette
mission est une mission secondaire mais
qui qui vient en appui du travail de
terrain de constatation d'infraction au
stationnement
donc là l'agent lui va constater cette
infraction donc lé matériel matérialiser
il va faire un relevé d'abord dans un
premier temps une situation globale avec
un cliché qui nous permet notamment de
voir la plaque du véhicule sa marque et
son mollet et puis ensuite on a dit
qu'on laissait un laps de temps de cinq
minutes entre ce premier relevé et la
constatation de l'infraction par pv donc
l'agent au bout de 5 minutes comment
sera rédigé le pv comme le ferait un
agent de terrain en fait sur son
terminal de vidéo-verbalisation ce qu'on
voit exactement à l'image exactement
donc tout se fait à distance ça veut
dire qu'il ya plus de contacts entre la
personne verbalisée et l'agent
verbalisateur alors dans le cadre de
cette mission là c'est exact néanmoins
je rappelle les agents de terrain
continue de verbaliser c'est pas un
remplacement c'est vraiment un
complément donc on continuera de voir
des agents de la police municipale et
devoirs des asvp les agents de
surveillance de la voie publique
faire ce type de missions sur le terrain
est ce qu'une tolérance peut être
appliqué dans le cadre d'une
intervention d'une ambulance d'un
médecin d'un infirmier ou est-ce que
c'est compliqué c'est pas spécialement
compliqué parce que ce sont des
véhicules que l'on va distinguer du
reste des véhicules classiques
lorsqu'un médecin une infirmière va
avoir un caducée sur son pare-brise et
puis les agents de vidéo verbalisation
les agents du cs une le centre de
supervision urbain ont exactement le
même discernement qu'un agent de terrain
l'aurait lorsqu'il est sur place faut
être clair avec les caméras on peut
zoomer vraiment beaucoup
au point de voir ce cas du ces sur le
pare brise tout dépend la distance à
laquelle on est de la caméra en question
mais effectivement on peut voir des
détails comme celui ci oui et non et
dans ce cadre là donc on sera conciliant
avec le médecin ou l'infirmière
alors tout dépend la durée bien entendu
si c'est un stationnement de courte
durée mais gênant on va rentrer dans le
cadre des cinq minutes dont on a parlé
un prêt si ça dure des heures évidemment
de la même façon qu'un agent t1 relèvera
l'infraction l'agent du csu le fera
également et donc il en coûtera 135
euros pour les stationnements très
gênant